[Music]
satellite images from this year show how
china is expanding its military arsenal
from missile launch sites in remote
deserts to aircraft carriers
and submarines at sea
china's buildup in recent years has been
unprecedented while china's military
spending is much lower than the us its
defense budget has more than doubled
over the past decade
the build-up is aimed at meeting
beijing's goal of having a world-class
military by 2049 the 100th anniversary
of the founding of the people's republic
of china china perceives the us
increasingly as a threat and wants to
find ways of countering the united
states which operates as the premier
power broker in asia
the wall street journal analyzed recent
satellite images from maxar technologies
and planet labs and spoke to military
experts who studied them and they reveal
how beijing is advancing its nuclear and
naval arsenal to take on the us and its
allies
china successfully tested its first
nuclear weapon in the 1960s and since
then it's developed a few hundred
warheads according to u.s government
estimates that's far less than the
roughly 4 000 the u.s has
however in the past year or so beijing's
stance has shifted the chinese
leadership has decided that it needs a
lot of nuclear weapons compared to what
it had before hans christensen has been
studying china's nuclear development for
more than four decades and is currently
with the federation of american
scientists a non-profit policy think
tank based in washington dc
satellite images show china's been
adding what appears to be missile launch
facilities in the remote deserts of
central and western china zoom in and
you see this they put up these big
inflatable domes over the silo
construction sites both to protect
against climate but also to protect
against um you know spy satellites and
things like that when the basic
construction is done the inflatable
domes are taken down revealing silo
fields these contain huge canisters that
are built into the ground and can be
used to house nuclear-tipped missiles on
this elevated dirt mount christensen
says there appears to be a silo hatch
which is a lid to a missile canister
and there's also a wide road that could
be used to transport missiles on trucks
in the past two years or so christensen
has observed more than 300 silos under
construction across china up from some
20 the country used to have before 2018.
and he says the primary focus of these
silos would be to expand china's nuclear
arsenal china's development indicates
that it's sort of it has begun to think
that it is more vulnerable to attack
than it was before
military analysts say one of these sites
is large enough for a new long-range
chinese missile which can carry nuclear
warheads and is capable of reaching the
us mainland while the chinese government
hasn't officially confirmed or denied
the construction of these miso silo
fields beijing has pledged not to use
nuclear weapons unless provoked
china is also beefing up its navy that's
critical because about one third of the
country's borderline faces the ocean
at the southern edge of hainan island is
a chinese navy base
this satellite image shows two of
china's nuclear-powered ballistic
missile submarines
military analysts say it's the only
vessel in the chinese navy dedicated to
launching nuclear weapons it's china's
first credible sea based deterrent
matthew funiole is a senior fellow with
the center for strategic and
international studies his team obtained
these satellite images from maxar
technologies in order to analyze china's
military development funioli says china
is relatively new to deploying such
submarines which are capable of
launching ballistic missiles that can
reach as far as 5 600 miles and the
chinese military says each submarine
could carry up to 12 of them in the
region itself you know the jail 2 could
certainly strike india could strike
russia but if you're thinking about
whether or not it could strike targets
across the continental united states um
not not so much
another significant upgrade to china's
naval fleet a newer aircraft carrier
this satellite image shows a shipyard in
shanghai and since at least 2018 china's
been building what military analysts say
will be the country's biggest aircraft
carrier the new vessel is bigger than
its two predecessors and this extra
space means a longer and wider flight
deck for larger and more powerful
aircraft to take off what that gives you
is that you can generate a lot more lift
to try to get heavier airframes into the
air so more fuel and a lot of cases
bigger aircraft and do so at you know up
tempo at you know at faster speed while
china has revealed little information
about the aircraft carrier funioli says
satellite images show that the vessel
could be equipped with an advanced
launch and recovery system like the one
used by u.s and french aircraft carriers
with this design a catapult launches the
aircraft
and during landing arrester wires catch
it the pentagon expects the vessel to be
operational by 2024 and when deployed
china will be able to project power
farther away from the mainland it gives
china a flexible tool to sail your
aircraft carrier fleet through a
strategic waterways way of sending a
signal to other regional powers
to prepare for potential conflicts with
other military powers satellite images
also showed china constructing what
appears to be mock-up models in the
shape of a u.s vessel in the desert
military analysts say the chinese army
is increasingly focused on creating
realistic training environments and it's
not just against us troops but also
other adversaries
for instance this satellite image shows
what appears to be a surveillance plane
in the desert and the aircraft looks
like one that's operated by the japanese
air force military experts say the size
and shape particularly the radar mounted
on the back of the plane indicate that
it's a japanese aircraft
china's ministry of national defense
didn't respond to a request for comment
on questions about the country's
military buildup
security experts say china's expansion
has been across a range of assets
because it's about looking beyond the
u.s as its only challenge china has a
very broad
horizon when it comes to potential
adversaries that is looking you know
almost 360 degrees around uh china those
adversaries include close us allies like
japan and south korea which are also
increasingly casting a wary eye on china
so as beijing continues to invest in its
arsenal and military technology security
experts say it's also pushing the us to
stay competitive to defend against any
potential threats from its rival